that's a good move Joey yeah we chose
pineapple strong zero I didn't know
Kieran had like a brand of strong zero
it's called Kieran the strong for this
job so it must be better than strong
zero hearings prime so if any of you
ever come to Japan and there's one
beverage you should try out if you do
drink beverages alcoholically then
strong zero this is life strong this is
like what we call the the gaijin Killa
is what you guys called it right the guy
it's colloquially the gaijin killer
because it tastes like juice but then
you realize it's just as strong as like
a wine yeah so you just get but but like
it like percentage-wise is as strong as
a wine I don't know why it [ __ ] me up
way hard about any wine I've ever had
carbonated yeah I think I blacked out
every time is involved end up know me
like not remember drugs are a hangovers
easily the worst I reckon well the last
time we drank strong Cheers wow I I
don't remember off that night and then I
I woke up with like the most searing
headache I was like yes horrible you
guys remember your first drum zero
experience blacked out was it Japan we
had like an end of year party every year
and that was like the one drink everyone
drank and I woke up on a beach of five
six cans of six cans its formidable one
is like yeah you feel it too is like
woah oh god no and after that it's
blackout thanks how did you take you
Connor oh you in my I think it was like
the very first time I think it was like
three or four yeah for summary and I
cannot be handle my alcohol pretty why
how much you think you can hold out
whole yeah after three strong zeros it's
late inhumane no one can handle because
we're like three three Brits and an
Aussie we're very very used to drinking
but for some and here's the thing every
time we every time I see someone you try
strong zero especially if they're from
the UK they're like this is this 9
percent
this isn't gonna [ __ ] me up please I'm
gonna have like two cans and they're
like wasted already and then third count
is like I'm blackout I cannot remember
this night and I don't know what it is
about this particular drink
just maybe soju yeah this is the
greatest prank you can put on your
friends that we bring to Japan it's just
like
fizzy water is fine things happen if
it's crazy the businessmen just drink
them that like I see I see MIT like they
think 1 p.m. sometimes just having one
eyesight the conbini yeah damn well p.m.
it's time to drink oh yeah
seriously then I'm flying around here
okay now they gonna optimize all the
free time they have you know what I mean